Vegeta has been coming for Kakarot for decades
now in Dragon Ball – and in the post-credit
scene of the new "Dragon Ball Super" movie,
the unthinkable finally happened. Warning:
spoilers ahead for "Dragon
Ball Super: Super Hero."
"You need to believe in yourself,
and unleash that power."
The 21st feature installment in the "Dragon
Ball" series dominated the US box office
after its first weekend in theaters,
taking the number one position with a
$20 million opening – twice the take of its
predecessor, "Dragon Ball Super: Broly."
Of course, "Dragon Ball Super: Super Hero"
hasn't just made an impressive financial
impact. Much like its predecessor, the new
film has received overwhelmingly positive
reviews from critics and seems to be doing even
better among casual viewers. The film's story,
which revolves around Piccolo and Gohan's
combined efforts to take down a dangerous,
reformed version of the Red Ribbon
Army, allows "Dragon Ball Super:
Super Hero" the chance to deliver
plenty of memorable scenes as well.
Not only does "Dragon Ball Super: Super Hero"
feature more than its fair share of instantly
iconic Piccolo and Gohan moments, but
the film also finds some time to turn
its attention to some of the "Dragon Ball"
franchise's other fan-favorite characters.
That's especially true in the film's
noteworthy post-credits scene,
which revolves around a twist that some "Dragon
Ball" fans may think has been a long time coming.
Before "Dragon Ball Super:
Super Hero" becomes fully
engrossed in Piccolo and Gohan's
fight against the Red Ribbon Army,
it takes a moment to briefly check in with
Vegeta and Goku. At the start of the film,
the two "Dragon Ball" fighters are on Beerus'
planet and in the midst of training. Once that
has been established, "Dragon Ball Super: Super
Hero" becomes largely preoccupied with Piccolo,
Gohan, and the pair's various Red Ribbon Army
combatants. Most of the movie is focused on
their fight, giving "Dragon Ball's" less-powerful
players a chance to shine on the silver screen.
However, before "Dragon Ball Super: Super
Hero" cuts to black for the last time,
the film does take a moment to bring things full
circle and check back in with Goku and Vegeta,
who have apparently spent the entire
movie in a fight of their own.
At the very end, "Dragon Ball Super: Super
Hero" delivers a genuinely surprising moment,
one that fans of the franchise may have previously
thought they'd never actually get to see onscreen.
When the film's post-credits scene begins,
both Goku and Vegeta are exhausted from
their off-screen fight. As their battle winds
down, Vegeta slowly throws one final, weak,
tiny punch that proves to be enough to force
Goku to admit defeat, toppling him to the ground.
Vegeta obviously takes a moment to truly
cherish his victory, before collapsing to
the ground himself, exhausted. Finally, after all
these years, he's technically defeated Kakarot.
Vegeta's victory over Goku is an undeniably
major "Dragon Ball" moment. However,
it should be noted that Vegeta gets his
win under very specific circumstances.
For starters, his and Goku's fight in the film
isn't a to-the-death battle but a sparring match,
with no energy blasts or transformational powers
being used. That means that the two combatants
are essentially forced to rely solely on their
martial arts skills and normal stamina levels.
All of which is to say that, while Vegeta's
win will likely still be celebrated by fans
of the character, "Dragon Ball Super: Super
Hero" does go out of its way to make it clear
that his fight with Goku isn't exactly
an all-out brawl. Earlier in the movie,
Vegeta also takes the time to
meditate before the battle,
noting his belief that doing so will give him an
advantage. The post-credit scene proves him right,
giving long-time fans of the Saiyan prince the
victory they've always wanted, at long last.